after graduation i did many things from
working in mechanical industry in
production line to teaching physics but
nothing worked out
so i decided to up-skill myself with
simplylearn's full-stack java developer
course and soon after the course was
over i cleared many interviews but
eventually i decided to join nova tech
with a very good package
hi
my name is joshin
and i work as a software developer in
nova tech after my graduation in 2018 i
worked as a mechanical engineer the job
included working in a small industrial
site and interacting with labor force
and after six months i left that job
after that i began teaching physics
during that period upskilled myself
because since my college days i've been
fascinated by web development data
science ai and machine learning but
being a mechanical engineer it was
really difficult for me to get a
competitive job in the market
but a belief when you upscale yourself
you invest a lot of time money and for
that i chose simply learn it is already
renowned and it has a brand that i trust
and also the arrangement of the content
and the job guarantee program made it
more interesting the course was great
with the regular updates on the upcoming
technologies
the mentors were really experienced and
supportive we had a different mentor at
every stage so they were highly skilled
in the subject the mentors for java
fundamentals and spring boot were
excellent i believe that the course was
a complete package for me
there was a lot of content to go through
and it was more than enough for me to
crack a job into it the arrangement of
the topics was structured
and after every stage of the course we
had small quizzes which helped me clear
my doubts and understand better i didn't
have any experience in coding but this
course helped me understand it which
boosted my confidence
i want to learn more and in the future i
would like to become an entrepreneur as
a developer you must accept that errors
are part of your life and a problem you
face while learning is comparable to an
error in the code
all you need to do is solve
and as you solve more frequently your
skill will develop and become better and
stronger
[Music]